bonjour à tous en quelques mots je tiens
à vous présenter quelques facettes de
cet extraordinaire canton de saint louis
une particularité forte et la
coexistence de zone très urbanisée à
fort développement économique avec un
arrière-plan de typique villages et
paysages ruraux ainsi une personne qui
arriverait via l'avion découvrira la
modernité des équipements et des
bâtiments l'euroairport et cinq minutes
plus tard il pourra visiter la réserve
de la petite camargue mille hectares il
reprendra ensuite la route qui longe les
champs d'aspergés de village neuf et
arrivera le quart d'heure suivant à bâle
et tout en étant au pied des bâtiments
des plus grands architectes mondiaux
érigé au campus novartis caen puis sauve
artiste lui-même sous le regard de la
tour des établissements roche
il ne sera qu'à moins de 20 minutes de
la semaine avec son château du landskron
ou de cnh langue comme aujourd'hui
devant cette typique maison du sud
alsace en bref le canton de saint louis
ce m de plain pied dans le xxième siècle
tout en préservant son cadre
environnemental traditionnels en plus de
cette volonté de conjuguer modernité et
tradition tous les élus ont toujours été
attentif aux services rendus à la
population
et récemment ce fut pour pérenniser
l'existence de notre clinique de saint
louis dans les villages ruraux du canton
les élus locaux les élus du conseil
départemental du conseil régional et les
parlementaires
tous ont toujours veillé à la présence
de services publics de proximité en
travaillant toujours étroitement
ensemble et avec les services de l'état
et bien c'est une multitude de nouveaux
services qui ont été rendus dans les
villages ruraux comme par exemple le
raccordement la station d'épuration de
village-neuf qui a permis de ne plus
laisser les eaux usées polluer le milieu
naturel
ce sont des crèches hagenthal le bas ou
à ranspach-le-bas c'est une maison
pluridisciplinaire de santé comme ici à
folgensbourg c'est une gendarmerie
hagenthal au une zone économique à
athènes filaire etc
il ya plein d'exemples et c'est ainsi
qu'il ya de moins en moins de fracture
territoriale en termes d'équipements
structurants entre zones urbaines et
zones rurales
al le seul bémol et en l'absence de
commerces de proximité
en ce moment le grand chantier et le
déploiement de la fibre optique sur tout
le territoire et le grand défi de demain
sera le développement des transports en
commun sur tout le canton
nous sommes actuellement à la mène au
pied du château du landskron derrière
moi et cet endroit symbolise tout le
potentiel de développement touristique
de notre canton et plus largement de
toute l'alsace côté sud en tant que
président d'alsace destination tourisme
je tiens à rappeler le poids du tourisme
en alsace 2,2 milliards d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires trente sept mille
emplois non délocalisables et +2 5% du
pib avec l'euroairport
nous avons la chance de disposer de la
porte d'entrée du tourisme alsacien en
plus de nos propres atouts nous avons à
nos portes la capitale mondiale de l'art
moderne qui et bâle ainsi que le sundgau
qui correspond à cette attirance
actuelle pour le tourisme vert ainsi en
matière d'art notre touriste palais au
kunstmuseum à bâle mais aussi à faire
des branques à saint louis et en voiture
dès la sortie de l'autoroute a35 le
décor change en un éclair
et l'on se retrouve sur les routes du
sundgau et de la carpe frite pour aller
faire des randonnées autour des châteaux
de ferrette du morimont et bien sûr de
la semaine comme aujourd'hui
avant de terminer sa visite autour d'une
bonne table et de dormir dans un hôtel
ou chez l'habitant dans un gîte rural
je conclurai en disant que le canton
saint louis avec ses relations avec
l'allemagne et la suisse avec ses
milliers d'habitants qui traversent
chaque jour des frontières qui n'en sont
plus constitue une petite europe du
quotidien une petite robe du quotidien
avec beaucoup d'attraits touristiques
tel un diamant et tout comme l'alsace ce
canton de saint louis a de multiples
facettes de multiples facettes qui
brille tout autant les unes que les
autres
merci de m'avoir écouté